little Twilight Breaking Dawn Part 2
reunion with rami malek
now tonight is is more than a fancy
party there's a goal tonight can you
talk a little bit about what tonight is
about and why it's so close I mean I
just love the people who run the
organization I really really really
trust them and I mean I've never had any
I I've never had a personal connection
with the charity before and it's kind of
it's just a completely different thing I
know exactly what Scott Fife is doing
every year and I did this one thing I
got involved with them
maybe five years ago doing I just you
know you're always doing something or
shooting off a day on set or whatever
and I we I think it was a day on set of
Twilight on one on Breaking Dawn and I
didn't even think about it and then I
came to this gala and there's this video
the school in Cambodia specifically from
that auction item and I was like wait I
can I'd never seen that direct
connection but with fundraising and
seeing exactly what it does and I just
thought it's very it was really powerful
and kind of I mean every year it just
gets bigger and bigger and it's kind of
they're just I think they're really good
people who run it so many powerful names
here tonight I got to know are you gonna
pick Chris Evans brain about a plate of
soup we're gonna pick who's right I may
be
[Music]